did you break the ministry of food
it would be first ministers questions
but not as she knows it
nicola sturgeon made the trip to
parliament with her political future on
the agenda
and on the line i will tell the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth alex salmond had been last in the
hot seat
with a hint of emotion nicola sturgeon
told how she'd watch the performance
of the man she once knew as her bestie i
found myself
searching for any sign any sign at all
that he recognized how difficult this
has been
for others to first and foremost for
women who believed his behavior towards
them
was inappropriate but also for those of
us who have campaigned with him
worked with him cared for him and
considered him a friend
on one of the key allegations of
breaching the ministerial code
did she discuss complaints against alex
salmond at a meeting with his former
chief of staff jeff aberdeen on a date
before she told parliament she knew
about them
no said nicola sturgeon they had a
meeting but the chat
was more general jeff did indicate that
a harassment type issue had arisen but
my recollection is that he did so in
general terms
since an approach from sky news in
november 2017 and i
mentioned this in my written evidence to
the committee i had harbored
a lingering suspicion that such issues
in relation to mr salmond might view
their head
she reaffirmed that she only found out
about the complaints days later
at a meeting in her kitchen when alex
salmond produced a letter
and although he denied the allegations
he gave me his account
of one of the incidents complained off
which he said he had apologized for at
the time
what he described constituted in my view
deeply
inappropriate behaviour on his part this
hollywood committee had previously heard
from alex salmond
the nicolas sturgeon offered to
intervene upon learning of complaints
against him
she insisted otherwise my head was
spinning i was
dealing with kind of complicated
emotions
you're sitting with a friend who's
saying ah i'm facing this terrible
situation
things like you know i'd love to help if
i could kind of thing
the salmon sturgeon combination is the
political force that fell apart
from both we've seen a quality in
performance here
the quality of answers will be a matter
for the watching public
and committee the scottish conservatives
have already made their decisions
they're pursuing a vote of no confidence
in the first minister
in parallel to a grueling eight-hour
evidence session
the scottish conservatives have been
pressing for a vote of no confidence in
the first minister
she was pressed for a view on her
predecessor
i don't know whether he ever reflects on
the fact that
many of us including me feel very let
down uh
by him and you know that's that's a
matter of deep
personal pain and regret for me i um
i think i probably should stop there
this inquiry process
is nearing its end its focus is on
government policy
government personnel remain in the frame
james matthews sky news edinboro